Ngoài 2, 2, 3, 2, 3, 4, 5,
Công ăn tính tình tình bắt sử bà nghe phạm đến cua đến vụ ám mạng sế ra tại công ty chế giềm hiểu hạm
TV chuyển phát dành TV, đống trên địa bản sả nhỉ tỏ.
Chứ đó, khoảng 2,5 phút hùng qua, có ba đối tượng năm, đào khổ chang,
đi trên một xem máy từ cố lộ một vào khu vực cộng công ty.
Sù đó, 2 đối tượng đi bộ vào bên trong, nơi công nhân đang làm việc,
tiếp cận bản lần việc của anh hát tế, 8,5 tuổi, 1 tình biến lắm, là tuổi trường xả sức.
Tại đây, các đối tượng đã tình công an a khiến nạn nhân gục ngá,
về án sông, 2 đối tượng bỏ trẻ lên xem máy só đối tượng còn lại trở sánh,
tổ thó vị hủ phụ tình an.
Các công nhân trong đối an a thì cấp dữ,
tình nhân nạn nhân đã tự vong trước khi nhập việt.
Sau khi buộc việc sẻ ra, lực lượng công an đã nhìn trong truy sét
và bác sữa 2 đối tượng trước trước khi an là lề biến tình, 2 mi tụi,
chú tại thành phố xin mình và tạc quan lình,
bây chiến tội chú tại tình tình tình.
Cả hai tưởng là công nhân của công ty,
đã nghĩ việc khoảng 4 ngày trước khi sẻ ra vụ việt.
Ngoài ra, các quan công an cũng tạm giữa phạm mình phó,
2 niềm bà tuổi, 1 xa cần dục,
tình tên nhìn,
là người điều khiến sẽ một tổ chờ cơ đối tượng lên quan đến của an.